this is a production of Cornell
University all right all right good
morning everyone or I suppose afternoon
now um as mentioned I'm p and I will be
talking about my research of working
towards cloning r y Inda a resistance
Gene against potato virus y so to begin
what is potato virus y also known as pvy
well it's a single stranded RNA virus
that infects potato among other Sol
anous s and as for the letter Y that
just happened to be the next letter in
the alphabet when scientists were naming
the viruses they had discovered this pvy
is transmitted by aphids and in
commercial production it can cause up to
80% loss in yield and that can be caused
either by stuned growth or necrosis in
the tubers as seen here in this picture
it's very ugly and um how it's managed
in commercial production is the use of
virus free seed and having come from a
potato farm in northern Wisconsin I very
much understand the importance of this
my family farm produces our own seed
potatoes to be used in commercial
production to produce tablock potatoes
which are the pigs of potatoes you see
at a grocery store so as a kid I would
grind up leaves for my mother to do an
Eliza test on to see how much PB was in
our seed potatoes so having done that as
a kid it's kind of cool now I'm working
with the virus as part of my PhD so um
PB does not only affect commercial
production it can also affect breeding
in the 2023 growing season the Cornell
potato breeding program lost about 75%
of our germplasm to pvy so that makes
Walter's job harder to release cultivars
that New York Growers need like
resistance to golden nematode because
there's just less to select upon making
it a lower probability of finding a
clone that is suitable to become a
cultivar so resistance is needed for
both commercial production and breeding
so looking to the resistance side of
things what is r y indena as mentioned
it's a resistance Gene against pvy R
standing for resistance and Y coming
from pvy it originated from the wild
tetrao species sanum tuberosum
subspecies andena so that's how we get
the subscript adg is just andena
abbreviated and in this research I've
been using the cultivar Eva which is a
Cornell bread clone released in
1999 and it's actually named after the
mother of Bob Playstead who was Walter's
predecessor so just a nice little plant
breeding trivia fact for you there so
we've been using Ry Inda successfully in
our program for over 20 years so why do
we care about cloning the gene well to
begin with you can do further
experiments on it to see how it confers
resistance on a molecular level as well
as you can develop a marker that is very
tightly linked with the gene because
once you clone it you know its exact
location within the genome and finally
you can edit current and future
cultivars for the desired trait so if a
clone is pvy susceptible you can add in
r y indigena to make it more marketable
to Growers so towards this effort r y
Inda has been mapped to chromosone 11 in
potatoes specifically in the region
between markers risk 3 and M45 and I've
been very fortunate to receive some data
from the international potato Center
where they created a segregating
population between the resistant clone
or cultivar costanera and the
susceptible clone lbr 43 and out of
about 6,500 genotypes they found four
Rec combinat within this region and then
using the phenotypes of these
recombinants and the markers listed here
they were able to narrow down the
interval of where r y indena could be to
in between markers m6 and
M45 so then they created a scaffold of
chromosome 11 from the ctar costanera
and on this region they identified
resistant Gene analoges rgas of a
specific resistance Gene type called
tnls and tnls are resistance genes that
have three domains a TI an NBS and an
llr so on this region they have 14 rgas
which is not a bad list to start with
but as previously mentioned they did
narrow it down to between markers M45
and M6 so narrowing it down our
candidate genes to five which is a
better number to start with but then the
same group also collected expression
data and found that RGA 12 9 11 and 14
were expressed in resistant clones so we
Mark those on our scaffold and we see
that rga1 is the only one within this
interval making it a pretty good
candidate but it's also important to
consider other research that's been done
in the field so there's been two other
Roi genes that have been previously
cloned and they've both been tnls so
looking a little bit more at their
structure Roi chensky has five axons is
a little over 4 KB long Ry Stow also has
five axons is about 4.8 KB long and then
rga1 also has five exons and is 4.5 KB
long so not only does rga1 fall within
the interval is expressed in resistant
clones but it also has a similar
structure to previously cloned Ry genes
making it our top candidate however of
course not everything can be butterflies
and rainbows because you know that's
just not how science works and we do
have these two missing sections of
sequence within the M45 M6 interval so
we do need to investigate those regions
because there still is the possibility
that r y indena could be in one of those
two sections so we have some
collaborators over at Oregon State who
assembled the Genome of Eva using pack
Biol lawn read sequencing and once that
was done they took the scaffold of
costanera and compared it to Eva's
genome to identify the genes within Eva
so rga1 correlates to Gene 57 within Eva
and then also we were able to
investigate those missing sections of
sequence indicated here by the white
regions and we saw that 43 was also a
possible candidate due to it also having
having five exons and the domains within
the gene so moving forward we'll use the
5743 annotation so we had these genes
synthesized via the company twist
bioscience both 57 and 43 as well as Roi
Stow to be used as a positive control in
our experiments and this was all
together about 13,000 base pairs and it
cost about
$2,500 and to me that seemed like a lot
of money but Walter you know the guy who
funds all of my research said like hey
that's actually not too bad of a price
so just a little side fact there for you
guys that it's not too expensive um so
anyway once we received the jeans I PCR
Amplified them to have two flanking
recombination sites on either side of
the Gene and then in the first reaction
of Gateway cloning I Rec took the PCR
product and a donor vector and
recombined the two to create an entry
clone and then in the second reaction of
Gateway cloning I took that entry clone
as well as a destination Vector that is
used for plant transformation recombine
the two to create an expression clone
then I took that expression clone and
transformed it into agrobacterium to be
used in a transient expression assay and
in this type of assay the goal is not to
create a transgenic plant but rather to
temporarily Express the protein so here
amethi plants were inoculated with
either pvy or pvx and pvx is just
another virus PV potato virus X so then
about two weeks later I confirmed virus
within the plants via a strip test it's
very similar to the co test we have all
taken a numerous amount of times where
two bands indicates the presence of the
virus so after virus was confirmed
within the plants I Agro infiltrated the
leaves with the agrobacterium um either
with the canidate gene or Ry sto
alongside a negative control called RX
which is a resistance Gene against pvx
so once those two Agro infiltrations
were done on each Leaf two to three days
later if a hyper sens of response was
observed on the leaves that means that
um the gene confers resistance against
that virus and this was the procedure
that um the paper that used to clone Ry
Stow did to narrow down their candidate
Gene so I know this would be applicable
to Ry Inda and also a hypers sensitive
response in this case would just be
localized cell death so our expected
results under the hypothesis that our
top candidate 57 is r y Inda we would
see a high percent response where it had
been aggro infiltrated in our pvy plants
and RX being the negative control there
be no response so 57 being r y indigena
that means 43 cannot be so there would
be no responses on the leaf and then Ry
sto being the postive control it would
have a hyper sensitive response and just
to confirm that ago infiltration was
done correctly on our pvx plants RX
would have a hyper sentor response on
all the areas it had been Agro
infiltrated and the canidate genes or Ry
Stow would have no response so I do have
some results fresh off the press
pictures taken this morning uh
so looking first at the pvx plants I saw
exactly what I expected to see um the
canidate genes and Roy Stow did not have
any cell death and RX on all the areas
it was infiltrated did have a hypers
sensitive response and then of course
the PB plants the question you're all
asking did she identify r y indena and
well I'm here to tell you not yet
um well so I didn't see any hypers
sensitive responses on the leavs even
Roi sto here I don't know if I can move
the mouse right there for people on Zoom
no hyper sensitive response um so
meaning that this assay might not be
reliable or I need to Tinker with it a
little more to see if I can get the
results I want um but yeah so working
forward stay tuned so but also that
tells me that this might not be as
reliable as it may be in a pvy system so
I have also done potato Transformations
on the cult ofar e Desiree um that is
pvy susceptible to certain strains of
pvy and then once those X plantlets grow
into plantlets they will be inoculated
with pvy to see if they confer
resistance within a potato system so
yeah that's where I'm at here are the
people I want to thank and my funding so
questions
Travis thank
you not yet um oh yeah so Travis asked
do I have any um expression data on the
genes identified if this will probably
take
forever okay in this region in that
missing section
uh currently I do not but that's
something we could look towards looking
at I had developed uh I designed primers
to do that but then we're just like hey
let's just test the ones we had right
now that's what I've been putting most
of my focus towards
Ed um I don't know how I can't I believe
it was RNA seek but I can't remember
exactly from the email what they had
said I think
yeah all right thank you for your
time and
that okay so so good afternoon I'm going
to use the topic I'm going to share is
using machine learning to represent
proteins and I'm going to see an example
on the SE storage
proteins okay so how protein structure
are able to help us to do the plant
breedings so the first part is right now
we are able to have all the protein
structure across different species in
plants so right now we are able to like
see why these plants are able to survive
in different kind of environment and the
other important thing is for the Del
mutation with the protein structures
right now we are able to say that these
might be the bad mutations so the
breeder might be able to pinpoint that
and select against them using the
techniques right
now another important thing we need to
mention is the distinct level of the
protein structures so the primary one
will be very easy and simple it's just
line up all the amino acid sequence into
one and then we'll get the primary
sequence and then the secondary
structure will be a bit more complicated
because we need to consider
the interaction between these amino acid
sequence and form like beta sheet or
Alpha
Helix for a bit more complicated we will
have a treasury structures and that will
be we have the backbone first and then
combine all the secondary structure
together and then form the these 3D
structures as you can see from the
primary secondary to the ter it is from
less complex to the more
complex and luckily right now we have
lots of different kind of machine
learning tools able to help us to
describe the protein structures so for
the primary and secondary right now we
are able to use a tool called protor and
then they're able to help us do these
structures and for the 3D structure or
the Trey structures Alpha 42 might be
the most famous one it is developed by
Google Deep Mind and they use multiple
sequence alignment to do the structure
predictions and the other is developed
by meta or previous called Facebook it
will they develop a tool called esm f
they use the Evolution scale modeling to
do the structure predictions so that
take a very very brief that how alpha F2
works so you'll need the input sequence
it is on the left hand side of your of
your slide and then the first thing
we'll need to do the multiple sequence
alignment across different species and
the second part is we need to like
compare between the protein database to
see that if these structure are already
be identified by previous researchers
and then we need to combine these two to
a Transformer model to do the 3D
structure predictions that'll be very
brief that how alpha Vol 2
works and the other tools that is called
prot Trend the input data will be same
just input the sequence data and then we
will use the tokenizer and encoding put
these data into a Transformer models and
then it will output a
1024 embeddings for us and embedding is
just a very fancy way to see that it's
just a list of number and able to help
us to represent that proteins so
embedding is just a vocabulary word for
the machine
learning so with these amount of tools
so how are we able to classify these
protein based on their functions so the
easiest way to start is start from SE
story protein because it is very well
studied and in maze when we see the
kernel 75% that of them are Hy carbon
hydrate and 10% of them are proteins and
amount these 10% 70% of them are the
seed story proteins and the seed story
protein can be also divided into four
parts so to get all the SE story protein
across different kind of plants we go to
a datab base called unios knowledge base
or also known as unios KB so in that
database there are around 4,000 protein
sequence for us to able to download them
and that protein is also across 400
different species including like
ariopsis so soybeans right or Etc these
kind of
plants okay we have the sequence right
now but which tool should we choose so
let's see we have Alpha F to ESN fold
and protrend so right now we can see
what's the input of the data do these
two need multiple sequence alignment why
we care about this because multiple
sequence alignment will take times and
it is need lots of computational
resource to do these kind of things and
only alha 2 needs need this things and
are they able to predict like 3D
structure or two three structures and
Alpha 2 and esnf do have the ability to
do this but protr does
not and the other very important thing
is are they able to recognize single
residue that means if we input a
sequence or I me a protein into the uh
tools or models and we change one only
one single residue about this sequence
are these two able to distinguish these
two and we know that Alpha f 2 and ESN
fold are not able to distinguish only
one single residue but protr are
sensitive enough for us to help us to
disting distinguish between these two
and the other is the speed we can know
that ala2 need multiple sequence
alignment and Es andf is also not that
fast as
protor and the last we're going to
compare is the output complexity because
Alpha fold 2 and ESN fold are structure
prediction so their output is their
structure so it will be not that easy
for us to do the down string analysis
however protrend like I just said it
will only be 1024 embeddings so we can
use that embedding to help us do the
downstream
analysis okay so what how are you going
to classify the C protein as I just said
we have the sequence or amino SD
sequence right now and we need to run
through a machine learning tool called
Pro and get their embeddings like I just
said embedding is just a number that are
able to help us to recognize their
proteins and because there's 1024
Dimension is not that easy for a human
to really visualize that so we need to
narrow down to two Dimension and the way
we did is use T sneak it's just a
fancier way of the PCA and then to see
what are we able to classify them or not
so there's the result we can see that
the Red Dot and the Green Dot are Artois
or the mace protein s but the blue one
these dots are the C story protein that
we just downloaded so we can see that
prot Trends are really able to help us
to recognize the C St protein based on
their
function okay right now we need to
annotate that all the C Ser in Ma so
what should we do we use the same data
that we download from uni Pro and then
we have another data download from n GDB
that is around 40,000 Amino sequence we
have these input we all run through prot
Trend and we'll get a very large table
so the First Column will be the sequence
name and the rest of it will be like I
just say a list of number that are able
to represent that proteins so what we
are going to do next is we will label
the C story protein as one and the Maze
genome as zero and split them 80% to do
the training and 20% to do the testing
to see are we able to use these number
to do the logistic regression to
recognize it is a C protein or it's just
a maze
protein and the answer absolutely is yes
accuracy is super super high it
99.56% and as you can see the
probability density plot you can see a
very clear split between the C to
proteins and the Maze
prote so be in the conclusion that we
are able to use machine learning to
classify C Surin based on the functions
and in this case we use the protrend to
help us to recognize the seed storage
proteins so my future work will be right
now we are able to cross 400 different
species right so we can use this model
to recognize almost every plant around
the world and then find all their seed
stor proteins and then when we find
these proteins we can start to analyze
like their carbon nitrogen efficiency or
their expression outside of their of the
seed or nitrogen ability or life history
of that plant and not just seeds to
protein with this model when we change
the input data we might be able to
recognize the other function of that
proteins and also it would works on
different kind of plants also and the
third part might be once we have these
protein models we are able to do the
whole genome or whole proteum annotation
across thousands of PL thousands of the
genomes so I think with that I would
need to thank everyone in my lab that
just not just like tell me not thing
they also teach me how to survive in the
US especially for the winter
time and thank you and happy to take any
questions
of
identifying that's a very H I need okay
let me repeat the question again so joh
question is in my input data like in the
M GDB there might be some sear for the
inside of that and the result that I
showed is very clear and so where are
that se proteins that is a very
wonderful question because I know the
answer as you can see very closely you
can see that there are some prot over
here and that's the reason why we cannot
get 100% I think protr can really do
very good classifi and the C is right
over here you are correct there are some
seats inside of that
data yes yes I think like five to 10
they are still like unannotated
why you that also great great question
so as you can see oh let me repeat the
question so sarin asked that there might
in a SE story proin there might share
common features but not shared like
across all the SE St there might be some
different amount that and then yes you
are totally correct in the C they are
really not Shar like very very common
feature they do have some sub family in
these SE storage protein so that's the
reason why we cannot see in this figure
they are all classify or cluster
together in one place and in C they
might be able to separate into like
three subgroup of that and then inside
these subgroup they are really close to
each their feature are really close to
each
other
hey struct to mention nitrogen use
efficiency
oh that would be the hard question
okay okay okay that but but I think able
to I think the protein structure link to
the efficiency that would be a bit hard
question right now because right now
after we recognize the C we need to
understand the structure of that are
they able to be digest by even like
human or animals of that but still I
right now I don't know how to study
their digestions about that but we can
study
their like carbon nitrogen ratio due to
using their amino acid sequence to see
that if they are high nitrogen in the
seat or they are different or they are
lower nitrogen in the seat but I don't
know how to study digestion right
now
okay
stages
doy the seed storage you see the protein
accomodation also change
oh the question
is different stage of the seat
do do do they have
different do they have different like
different structure of that but I think
in our model we are not doing like that
we use directly through their hold you
know we right now we don't does not like
sample in at different time
scale so I think they might be the same
but the expression level might be
different but these are all the sea
storage
properties
yay thank you
did this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu